>> FELT GOOD.
ALL RIGHT.
FELLAS.
THIS IS MY FAVORITE SCENE IN THE
SHOW.
THE COURT AND THESE KIDS'
RELATIONSHIP.
>> YEAH, THE COACH IS BECOMING A
FATHER FIGURE HERE?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
ALL RIGHT, SO I'M GONNA STAY OUT
OF YOUR WAY.
LET THE GENIUSES DO THEIR THING.
OKAY.
HERE WE GO, GUYS.
HEY BACKGROUND, CAN WE SAY WE'RE
JUST PLAYING SOME BALL?
PASS IT.
YOU KNOW THE DRILL.
ALL RIGHT, HERE WE GO, GUYS.
READY BACKGROUND ACTION?
>> ROLLING SOUND.
ROLLING, ROLLING.
>> AND ACTION.
♪♪♪
>> HEY, ROBBIE.
STAY IN THE ZONE.
YOU ARE SORT OF PASSING BACK AND
FORTH AND IT LOOKS A LITTLE BIT
WEIRD.
YOU JUST DRIBBLE PAST.
>> ALL RIGHT, SIR.
THANK YOU.
>> OKAY, GUYS.
TAKE IT FROM THE TOP AND ACTION.
>>
>> COACH STAN.
WHAT ARE YOU DOING HERE?
>> CAME TO SEE IF EVERYTHING WAS
OKAY.
WE MISSED YOU AT TRYOUTS TODAY.
>> I HAD SOME STUFF I HAD TO DO.
YOU WILL HAVE SCOUTS LINED UP
AND WAITING TO GIVE YOU A FULL
RIGHT TO THE SCHOOL.
I BELIEVE IN YOU.
SO MUCH SO, THAT I HAD THIS
FRIDAY.
>> AND CUT.
YOU ARE LOOKING SLOPPY RIGHT
NOW.
>> I TOOK A SPORTS CLASS AT
JUILLIARD.
>> THANK YOU.
>> AND ROLLING.
AND ACTION.
>> THROW IT.
>>.
>> I BELIEVED IN YOU.
TAR SO MUCH SO.
>> GUYS, STOP HUGGING PLEASE.
>> I DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT IS.
>> THE BALL IS HOT.
THE BALL IS HOT.
>> WE TOSS A ROCK.
DON'T LOOK INTO THE CAMERA!
KEEP GOING, GUYS.
>> I'M HERE.
I MEAN SO MUCH SO THAT I SET UP
A SECOND.
>> DON'T TAKE YOUR SHOES OFF.
STOP FIGHTING.
BACKGROUND.
HEY, SORRY.
WE WILL HAVE TO LOSE YOU.
SORRY, GUYS.
>> YEAH!
YEAH!
>> YOU GUYS ARE STILL FIRED.